fashion review
that's right that's what this channel
needs right now
a top 10 list finally
a top 10 list of something i know barely
anything about
that'll do it that'll get them watching
so i wanted to make another video on
fashion
but specifically fashion memes and i had
a few
things in mind already but i still asked
you guys on twitter
for some suggestions and oh boy there
was a lot of fashion
memes out there hey you want to look
like a dragon pair
what in the world i think it's safe to
say that fashion and memes are
becoming closer and closer
you have these uh steal his look memes
remember those
very cheap price very good price but
let's go through
my top 10 fashion memes list everybody
yeah for some reason i thought it was a
good idea to do a top 10 of this
number one valencia
ikea bag that's right everybody high-end
designer balanciaga
they call it the arena extra-large
shopping tote
it's going viral because do you notice
that it looks something similar to
maybe the
[Laughter]
how many meatballs can i fit in that bad
boy you could get the balenciaga
designer bag for two thousand one
hundred and forty five dollars
or the low low price of ninety nine
cents for ikea's
fracta and best of all no assembly
required on that particular idea i don't
know
just to represent sweden i also really
like the
ikea yeezys so yeah for the low price of
you too can embrace swedish culture i
mean i practically grew up with these
bags
it's kind of funny ikea responds to
balicia against blue bag in the best
way possible so they responded with a
meme
it wasn't really much of a meme it
really was kind of disappointing
number two unintentional vegan
do you want to dress up looking like a
bagana oh i'm sorry let me rephrase that
vagana just for
a thousand dollars that's right i know
which option you're picking
well look no further this fendi scarf
looks like
[Music]
you know i feel bad if anyone's seen a
vagana like that i'm sorry
here's the upside down version maybe
this item in particular
should have been on a model and not just
shown itself
just just a thought food for thought or
just thought
number three on our list everybody
that's right we're going fast
we're going hard here's a meme that i
personally fell for
that's right i bought this belt i really
like this brand it's the alex
roller coaster belt you've probably seen
these they're quite popular
they go for 273 pounds
they're really cool belts okay stop
hating
don't judge me okay they're cool belts i
like the
brand what do you want from me you can
buy these uh ripoff ones for uh 30 bucks
i've seen even less obviously you
shouldn't
you shouldn't do that okay don't don't
steal
the reason why i'm bringing up the the
copy is because the original
the 273 pound one it doesn't fit
it doesn't fit any pants you can't wear
this belt
so you pay you pay over 300 for a belt
that you can't use
good job i have to help out the people
that are curious on to
how to actually put this damn belt to
use i know a lot of people how the hell
do i put
money on this and
can't even get use out of it which is
unfortunate but
i'm here to help so what are the tips so
what are the tips
this is not fitting in here that makes
no sense like
you just cannot do it practically if you
want to wear this belt you got to go to
a tailor
to enter the belt so if you want to
spend like i don't know an hour putting
the belt on you can
you can get it through but if you have i
don't know a different fabric material
you're
likely to just break your pants i don't
know
sad just sad
number four gucci gundam
do you want to dress like your favorite
anime character for the low price of one
thousand seven hundred dollars
cause gucci sold these uh jackets or
outfits
for uh for that price and on the
japanese market people were quick to
point out
that they look very similar to the
gundam outfits
i mean look at the cups look at the belt
look at the neck
the shoulders the boots it's pretty
similar
they even had the the red version of the
jacket it's a pretty jacket i'm not
gonna lie
i like i wouldn't wear it which was also
resembles to another gundam character
gucci made a statement about this
apparently where they said that
it wasn't intentional or maybe they've
watched gundam and that's how it sort of
happened but they can either
deny or confirm but considering how
gucci already does a lot of
anime or vintage anime inspired looks i
think it's safe to say that this um
this was an inspiration at least could
this be the world's most expensive
cosplay
number five everybody montclair they've
been doing a lot of collaborations
i think they call it montclair genius
honestly i think a lot of them are
really dope they did one with craig
craig green and uh it's pretty crazy i
saw a lot of you guys sending me this
one and i
i've seen it already i wanted to bring
it up in my last video this is just
the thing that i think a lot of people
don't realize these are just promotional
designs you may think who how how would
anyone possibly wear this this is just
ridiculous
they're not made to wear they're just
made to i don't know be promo
get people to talk about it and clearly
it works but
even then i can appreciate the design of
it i think it looks
awesome and then looking at the actual
commercial jacket of it
it's cool it's a cool jacket like i
would buy it unless i if i needed a new
jacket which i don't so i'm not gonna
spend money on it
it's a cool jacket i gotta give them
props that's not why i'm bringing up
montclair the reason why is because they
did a
collaboration with pierre paulo
and it said it's something i said it's
something to say the least i don't know
it looks like those dolls what are they
called again
they're interesting to look at i can at
least appreciate the design but i think
what blows my mind on this is that these
are actually the commercial pieces that
you can buy
for 2 415 pounds and guess what
they're all sold out so even if you
wanted to
for some reason buy it you can't they're
sold out
all of them i want to see people wear
these they're probably really warm and
comfortable to be fair
can you imagine going out in a snowstorm
don't worry fam
i got just the outfit very nice number
six goes to video games that's right i
kind of combined this category
uh you've probably seen this it was a
few years ago where the final fantasy
character lightning did a collaboration
with louis vuitton
uh to promote these handbags and outfits
a way to hit a
very niche market of female gamers that
are also
loaded and also into high-end fashion
[Music]
funny enough i think today or maybe a
few days ago capcom
did a similar thing although they're not
collaborating with any fashion brand
they did launch their own clothing
pieces
uh as a connection to their launch of
their new game
devil may cry 5. so the three main
characters
they have a super luxury replica custom
version
super luxury to say the least uh you can
do uh
you can first of all get this uh jacket
that's missing half the arm
for seven hundred fifty thousand hundred
thousand yen
which i think is about six thousand
six hundred fifty dollars what's funny
about this is that you can buy it with
the video game
yes please give me the jacket and the
video game
so i can wear it while playing i mean
they're pretty pieces i think if you put
these in a high-end fashion store no one
would really question about it
combining it with with this video game
it's kind of silly but
i don't know there's something
interesting about it as well so this
jacket
is uh the scan version of that of
dante's jacket
it's a cool jacket another very very
expensive cosplay
to be fair it looks like extremely high
quality at least from what i can tell
from it you know people will be buying
you know people will be dropping
money on this big time i mean this final
fantasy or japanese type of games are
always made to
make the characters look cool in the
strangest way possible
so i kind of get it it makes sense i
just wonder who will fall for this meme
number seven i just spit everywhere
gucci
that's right they get their own category
congratulations
you know i wanted to just bring up their
face masks i wish i talked about it in
the last video
i was so confused why would people wear
these face masks i mean i bought one
myself so i guess i shouldn't be asking
that
they're silly to say the least but
they're not crazy expensive 175 pounds
please don't quote me on that i'm just
saying compared to all these other items
they're not
that crazy uh but the real reason gucci
gets on this meme is the fact that they
have this
sort of russian babushka inspired
outfits
like this one for example it's literally
the
get the look on this one shop the look
okay sure
that'll be six thousand okay sure
sure why not this was literally a meme
on my own subreddit gucci 5000
babushka half a dollar
look at that what is that
no no i don't know the thing with gucci
is like
they have all these really silly items
but like i mentioned in the last video
they do have
really cool pieces as well that i
genuinely
do like and ever since their latest
designer took in
they they honestly they've been killing
it so they get a high spot on the list
number eight moving on big shoes
everybody
another meme that i fell for i mean who
would possibly
buy big shoes why would anyone fall for
this me
you have the balinciaga shoes that got
super popular you have the gucci shoes
that are
really big and uh same sense i mean
they're so
similar it's almost like uh one type of
shoe gets popular and then all the other
brands just try and see
who can yell the loudest it's
interesting to look back at people's
opinion on these type of shoes
a year ago i know some people still feel
this way but
and make the worst shoe ever made that
they still will probably buy
eight hundred dollars not telling me 800
lives
whoa but now you see so many brands just
kind of taking and borrowing from this
design as well
uh i think that's interesting you know
people
first they laugh and then they they copy
it then you of course
have that one that one person that just
has to take it about five thousand steps
too far thank you vetements but
of course let's not ignore the godfather
of
sneakers the king of sneakers the meson
maguiela
fusion sneaker oh yeah just a thousand
four hundred pounds
you know most people when they buy
expensive sneakers they wanna make sure
that uh
nothing gets on them you know no dirt
whatsoever
uh with these you really don't have to
worry i think the more dirt the better i
love reading their reviews on these as
well
is this a joke this is the new low super
tacky fashion is in fashion if it makes
you look bad
pass i mean people clearly are buying
them from most places i
saw they were sold out
number nine we are getting there
everybody number nine goes to vetements
and what can i say about vetements well
uh they like
obviously they they like it big and
oversized
the thing though i'm a bit conflicted
about them because i don't
ironically it despite it looking very
silly
over the top and i think a lot of people
would probably ask why the hell
would you spend money on that i read
that i read this quote about veterans
that said i think the hype around
vetement says more about how boring
fashion is right now
than it does about vetements itself and
i honestly i kind of have to agree
they do cool pieces in a way that
is at least unique maybe it maybe i'm
wrong here i don't know
it's just like look at guys fashion for
example
it's t-shirts hoodies and sweatshirts
and it doesn't really get any weirder
than that it doesn't get
it really doesn't go outside of that box
at least for most people
i mean streetwear is basically as far as
it goes for most uh
most guys around my age or younger so i
like what they're doing i think it's
interesting
i also thought it was interesting with
their latest collection
the the designer comes from georgia and
uh he left qr codes
incorporated in his uh in his pieces
so that people can found out the story
about georgia
he said that growing up in georgia
everyone
wore the exact same clothes there mixing
fashion with spreading a message
so despite it being you know in a lot of
people's eyes very silly and over the
top
uh it does have some more depth to it as
well
and uh i don't know that's cool number
10 spot we finally did it
who's gonna take it obviously obviously
valencia i mean i've already mentioned
them so many times in this video
it's almost like they need a video on
its own they definitely deserve the
number one spot from the ikea bag
to the mcdonald's fry shoes half price
pounds very nice to the balenciaga crocs
super high heels to the balenciaga
supermarket
grocery bag through the balenciaga shirt
t-shirt shirt yes of course to their
bowling see i got multi-layered
jacket multi multi multi multi layer
jackets only 9
000. balanciaga is clearly leading this
meme this fashion meme of not taking
itself too
uh seriously at all i guess i don't know
but
same thing with vetements i think it's
interesting they're doing more
uh you know despite being very silly
everyone makes fun of balanciaga
it's like uh it's a thing they did a
collaboration with world food program
where they donated 250 000 to end world
hunger in 2030
and they give away part of their profits
from the sales
to this cost you can criticize it for
being overly expensive
and all these things but at least
they're doing something positive
my sweet daughter i have nothing more
proud
any last words
only one
well here is the newest item from
high-end clothing brand balenciaga
one of the items in their fall 2018 line
is a t-shirt
shirt it looks a lot like a t-shirt
attached to a collared shirt
if you think that's weird wait until you
hear the price the newest fashion trend
will cost you 1245 bucks that's it
i think it's easy to criticize how
ridiculously over the top and
overly expensive these items are and how
you can spend that money on literally
anything else
and you know i've done that myself it's
it's
it's a funny it's a it's a gag that
everyone plays into
but the thing is these brands know what
they're doing
i mean they know that the more people
talk about them the better
so while a lot of people show these
things to ridicule it
it obviously helps build the brands as
well and they are aware of it
it's the same with that kanye video you
know they they wear these stupid outfits
and everyone's like haha look how dumb
they look
it's not like they don't know what they
were wearing it's not like they just
accidentally fell into this outfit like
oh no this is so embarrassing
people talked about the video because of
the outfits and it's this exact same
thing
would this song have been popular
otherwise i think probably not
as much at the very least people always
seem to so upset
about the prices as well why are these
so expensive why would anyone
pay for this i always see like really
angry comments about it
but it's almost like the price sort of
legitimizes it
if these clothes didn't cost much then
people wouldn't care and if the clothes
didn't cost that much
then people wouldn't buy it people
wouldn't want it if these items were
cheap then
it wouldn't have that desirable effect
for people while we
so while a lot of people share these
items as a as a way to ridicule
and make fun of that's what makes it
possible for them to exist it's almost
like
while making fun of them we are making
fun of ourselves
that sounded very deep so on that note
i'm gonna end that video there what do
you guys think
let me know do you agree with this list
is there something i missed i
pretty sure there's a lot this was
interesting regardless leave a like if
you enjoyed and
i will see you guys tomorrow bye